-Welcome back.
It's been a while
since you've last seen us,
and you're probably wondering
why I'm not in the attic.
Well, if you recall,
two weeks ago,
I entered the attic door,
not knowing where it would lead.
And it turns out, it was a
portal to my in-laws' house.
And while I love my in-laws,
it is a slightly disappointing
outcome for a magic door.
I mean, if the wardrobe in
"The Lion, the Witch,
and the Wardrobe"
led to a TJ Maxx --
way different book.
Way less popular.
With that said, there's a lot
to like about the new space,
because there are
only three things
I ask for in a makeshift studio.
It has to be quiet,
has to have good Internet,
and it has to not be haunted by
the ghost of an old sea captain.
And this baby
checks all the boxes.
-Arggghh! Of that only a fool
would be certain!
-Now, there are some downsides.
I did not bring my beloved
copy of "The Thorn Birds"
with me on the journey,
but I assure you it is safe
under the watchful eye
of attic protector Ethan Hawke.
And he is the perfect choice
to guard "The Thorn Birds,"
as Ethan Hawke is America's
greatest avian-named actor.
Wait. Is that right?
-First one to miss
watches the winner eat.
-Yeah. Yeah, that's right.
But if I learned anything
in the portal,
it's to stop being so negative,
you know?
Celebrate the small things
in life that make us happy.
And I'm just [bleep] with you.
The US is an object
of horror and humiliation
across the world
as our coronavirus pandemic
spins further out of control
and a desperate president
tries to force students
and teachers back to school
without a plan
to keep them safe.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Let's just take stock
of where we are right now.
Four months after the first wave
of coronavirus lockdowns
as countries across the world
have successfully
suppressed their outbreaks
and resumed
some semblance of normalcy,
the outbreak here in the U S
is worse than it's ever been.
More than 130,000 have died.
The country just set a record
of nearly 70,000 new cases
in one day.
The state of Florida
shattered the national record
for new daily cases
with over 15,000.
People are lining up for hours
in the scorching heat
just to get tested.
Frontline workers
are again facing
potential shortages
of protective equipment.
Patients are waiting hours
in ambulances
to get hospital beds.
Scientists are now warning
of a potential wave
of COVID-related brain damage.
Unemployment is still worse
than it's been
since the Great Depression
as new claims keep pouring in.
Nearly a third of households
missed their
July housing payments.
As many as 28 million people
are facing eviction
by September.
Americans are banned
from traveling to Europe.
And we can't even eat
Goya beans anymore.
I mean,
what am I supposed to do?
Go back to Bush Beans?
Those beans invaded Iraq.
The point is,
the country's on fire
after a once-in-a-century
cataclysm
that has made us a pariah state
and an object
of national humiliation
to the rest of the world.
And, yet, this --
this is what the President
of the United States
is focused on.
-He hasn't taken
any cognitive tests
'cause he couldn't pass one.
I actually took one when I --
very recently when, I, uh --
when I was --
You know,
the radical left was saying,
"Is he all there?
Is he all there?"
And I proved I was all there
'cause I aced it.
I aced the test.
And he should take
the same exact test,
a very standard test.
I took it at
Walter Reed Medical Center
in front of doctors,
and they were very surprised.
They said,
"That's an unbelievable thing.
Rarely does anybody do
what you just did."
-The test you took
is basically a placemat
you give a child
at a restaurant.
If you gave this
to a 10-year-old
at Chuck E. Cheese,
they'd say, "Come on, man.
At least give me a maze
or a jumble. Challenge me."
That's like going
to the optometrist
and bragging
that you saw the "E."
Also, I'm willing to bet
Trump thinks he aced it
because the doctor who gave it
to him, Ronny Jackson,
probably told him he aced it
even if he didn't.
I mean, you guys remember?
You guys remember
sweaty Ronny over here?
The guy who said Trump
had the weight and build
of a college linebacker
rather than a divorced possum?
Of course, any doctor
who goes by "Ronny" is suspect.
Even a damn chiropractor
would call himself Dr. Ron,
if only to make sure
it fit on the vanity plate.
I'm sure when he looked
at Trump's test,
he had to say, "Mr. President,
you nailed it.
That IS a dog
with a knife for a nose."
Of course, if Trump
really wanted to prove
his intelligence,
he could show us the results
of the same tests
millions of other Americans
take every year,
and that's the SAT,
but as we learned,
last year he instructed
his attorney Michael Cohen
to threaten his schools
to never release his SAT scores.
And then last week, a tell-all
book by Trump's niece,
who's also
a clinical psychologist,
alleged that Trump
didn't take the SATs.
He paid a friend
to take them for him.
Now, that claim
has been disputed,
but, honestly, there's
no flattering option here.
Either Trump paid another kid
to take the SATs for him
or he took them himself
and his scores were so bad,
he refused to show anyone.
There's no, like,
third option here
where he kept his scores hidden
because he was afraid people
would know they were too good.
Trump's not some MIT janitor
solving math problems
and not telling anyone.
If he was, the teacher
would come in to find "FART"
scrawled on the blackboard.
"Did you do this?"
"It wasn't me."
"You signed your name."
Although I have to say, to me,
the most indelible quote
from the book
is Mary Trump's description
of her uncle's cognitive state.
Here's what she had to say.
Remember, this is the most
powerful man in the world
she is talking about.
But...he correctly identified
a camel on a piece of paper.
He came -- He came close.
He came close.
That's a relative
and a clinical psychologist
saying the President's brain
is so deeply broken
in so many fundamental ways
that, in order to
accurately diagnose him,
a team of scientists
would have to study him
extensively like some
sort of recently unearthed
15,00-year-old Cro-Magnon man.
She's talking about him
like they found him
encased in a block of ice
in a loin cloth.
He's "En-Senile Man."
-I'm hopeful this rank punnery
will not be commonplace!
-But don't worry.
If you're truly worried
that the President
of the United States
is a mentally incontinent
sociopath,
he put any questions
about his cognitive abilities
to rest by brandishing this
nifty little factoid on Friday.
-People don't remember,
nobody ever heard of it
until I came along.
Nobody remembered it
for a long time.
Or they didn't use it, at least.
I use it all the time.
Abraham Lincoln
was a Republican.
You know, you say that, people
say, "I didn't know that."
But he was a Republican.
So, uh, we're doing a great job.
-"Also, a lot of people
don't know Alexander Hamilton,
much like his country,
was young, scrappy, and hungry.
So, uh, you know,
we're doing a great job."
Obviously, what he means
is he didn't know
Lincoln was a Republican,
but my favorite part is when
he ends that dumb aside
with, "So, uh..."
Even he doesn't know what point
he was trying to make.
He's like a guy who's
running out of things to say
and just starts reciting facts
he learned
on Snapple caps
but mixes them up.
"People don't know this,
but beavers, uh --
beavers spend
two weeks of their life
waiting at traffic lights
for lizards to do pushups.
So, uh...
want to take the SATs for me?"
That's the guy overseeing
the worst response
to the coronavirus pandemic
anywhere in the world.
Just for some perspective,
on July 1st,
the state of Arizona alone
recorded more cases in one day
than the entirety
of the European Union.
Yesterday, according
to "The New York Times,"
Germany reported 159 new cases,
Canada reported 243 new cases,
while the US reported
a total of 57,789 new cases.
So, you know, perfect timing
for the President
to start wearing a mask.
Of course, he went with black.
It looks like there's
about to be a shootout
at the Golden Corral.
-Arggh! I will admit
that one tickled me!
-Seriously, dude,
get a different mask.
That color
combined with your mane
makes you look like
a muzzled horse.
Trump's team acted like this
was a big deal, but who cares?
You're four months late.
It's like someone saying,
"Should we not do
a live-action 'Cats'?" now.
It took Trump just as long
to learn that masks work
as it did for him to learn
that Lincoln was a Republican.
The rest of the world
is watching us
with pity and horror.
European countries are getting
back to some version of normal
while keeping
their economies intact.
In June, New Zealand lifted
all of its COVID restrictions
after declaring the country
virus-free.
Vietnam, a country
of nearly 100 million,
which shares a border
with China,
hasn't seen a domestically
transmitted infection
in nearly three months
and has recorded zero deaths.
And Japan just reopened concerts
and sporting events
to spectators, which is good
news, because, until recently,
at least one of
their baseball teams
was forced to fill the stands
with robot fans.
Those robots may look adorable,
but I assure you,
the adorable ones are
the first ones to turn on you
when the robot wars start.
Going to be a hell of a thing
when that's the last face
you see choking the life
out of you.
"Why?"
[Robotic voice] "Why did you
make me go to a baseball game?"
And many countries have also
reopened their schools
thanks to the success
in suppressing the virus.
Meanwhile, here in the US,
the President
wants to force
teachers and students
back into classrooms
as the outbreak worsens,
without sufficient health
and safety protocols in place
because he thinks
it'll help the economy
and, thus, his re-election.
-We have to open our schools.
Open our schools.
[ Applause ]
Stop this nonsense.
We open our schools.
Germany, Norway,
so many countries right now,
they're open,
the schools are open.
And they're doing just fine.
-Yeah, that's because
they suppressed their outbreaks,
you sadistic sack of laundry.
You rushed everyone back to work
too soon against the advice
of your own scientists
just to please the Dow,
and now we have 60,000
new cases every day
and we're banned
from traveling to Europe.
Do you know what that means?
If Americans can't go to Europe,
who is going to wear shorts
and Mickey ears to the Louvre?
And, look, everyone
wants schools to reopen.
Believe me,
I desperately want my kids
to go back to school
in the fall.
I mean, to keep them busy
during this,
I've had to put them
on the show,
and now they're demanding to
know when their next gig is.
They have agents now.
I walked by the little one's
room the other day
and heard him on the phone
demanding "points on the gross."
I don't think I get
points on the gross.
We might not have a giant gross.
I'm talking to
a different toy boat.
But Donald Trump
is the last person
I would trust
with my kids' safety.
He can't even be trusted
with Don Jr.'s --
By the way,
my father-in-law would be like,
"They're not toys.
They're antiques."
He can't even be trusted
with Don Jr.'s safety.
He let his oldest son
wander around the woods
until he eventually decided
to become one with the stumps.
Of course, eventually
the stumps made him leave
because he was too boring.
We just can't decouple schools
from the communities they're in.
If there are outbreaks
everywhere,
then schools are
going to have outbreaks, too.
Even in the best of times,
schools are a breeding ground
for viruses.
An elementary school
is like you took
a Five Points tenement building
and put it on the lido deck
of a cruise ship.
Every parent knows
if you have a child in school,
you basically have to put
DayQuil in your coffee
until they leave for college.
And if you're going to force
students and teachers to go back
amid a deadly pandemic,
you should at least --
at the very least,
have an idea
for how you're
going to protect them.
Instead, Education Secretary
Betsy DeVos
says it's up to you
to figure out
how you're going to
keep your kids safe.
And if you don't, they're
going to unilaterally strip
funding from your school,
which they don't even
have the power to do anyway.
-The US hit a record number
of new cases on Friday.
The number of new cases per day
is higher now
in 45 of the 50 states than
when schools shut down in March.
Hospitalizations are climbing
in several states,
and some ICUs
are at or near capacity.
So, yes or no --
can you assure
students, teachers, parents
that they will not get
coronavirus
because they're
going back to school?
-Well, the key is that kids
have to get back to school.
-You are compelling schools
to reopen
regardless of what's happening.
-No, what we're saying is that
kids need to be back in school.
-Why do you not have guidance
on what a school should do
just weeks before you want
those schools to reopen?
And what happens
if it faces an outbreak?
-You know,
there is really good examples
that have been utilized in the
private sector and elsewhere,
also with frontline workers
and hospitals.
-You can't even get
protective equipment
for doctors and nurses,
but you want schools
to operate like hospitals?
Why not go even further
and say schools
should operate like astronauts?
"There's really good examples
that have been utilized
on the International
Space Station.
If we launch all of our schools
into orbit,
then they can't get
coronavirus."
And, yet, that somehow
was not the dumbest remark
a Republican politician made
about re-opening schools
last week.
Florida governor Ron DeSantis,
who has overseen
an exploding pandemic
setting new records
in his state every day,
said we should treat schools
like hardware stores.
-If you can do Home Depot,
if you can do Walmart,
if you can do these things,
we absolutely
can do the schools.
-Yeah, man. Totally.
Last time I went to Home Depot,
they put me in
Remedial Weather Proofing
with 40 other customers
for eight hours,
and halfway through we took
a break to play kickball.
And if you're expecting DeSantis
to have second thoughts,
don't hold your breath.
Back in May, he had this to say
about those in the media
who criticized
Florida's re-opening.
-You've got a lot of people
in your profession
who waxed poetically
for weeks and weeks
about how Florida was
going to be just like New York.
"Wait two weeks.
Florida's going to be next.
Just like Italy.
Wait two weeks."
Well, hell, we're eight weeks
away from that!
And it hasn't happened!
-My first question is,
how come Ron DeSantis
gets his own Japanese robot?
And, second, why is anyone
taking a victory lap
in the middle of a pandemic?
No one knows how this ends.
The best most of us can do
is mitigate risk
for the benefit of ourselves
and others around us
and take steps to make sure
we're ready
for all contingencies.
You can't only have a Plan A,
especially when
the guy in charge
thinks "Plan A"
is how you spell "plane."
"Close enough, Mr. President!"
"Thank you, Dr. Ronny!"
When you're talking about
forcing children and teachers
to go back to schools
amid a deadly pandemic
you failed to stop without
even putting a plan in place
to protect them,
that's how you know you belong
to a sociopathic
political movement.
We're at the mercy
of a sadistic oaf
who's being shielded
by a political party
that cares more about statues
than people.
And, meanwhile,
the world is watching
the President's
deranged reaction
to a deadly pandemic
and asking themselves...
-Is he all there?
Is he all there?
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
So many New Yorkers are needing
to turn to City Harvest
for help feeding their families,
so City Harvest
needs your support.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe.
Wash your hands. We love you.